-Welcome, welcome, welcome
to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, today,
President Trump
visited a town in Texas
to mark the completion
of the more than 400 miles
of border wall.
When they heard Trump
was coming to the border,
Mexico was like, "Whew!
Thank God that wall is here."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, what a time to celebrate
the effectiveness of a wall --
six days after this happened.
[ Laughter ]
You know
your presidency is off the rails
when you have to distract
from your attempted coup
with your giant symbol
of racism.
[ Laughter ]
But this was interesting -- when
asked what he was doing there,
Trump said,
"I'm just planning my escape.
That seems like a good route."
Meanwhile, the wall only covers
20% of the U.S.-Mexico border.
20%.
Let me ask you a question.
If you ordered a pizza
and only got 1 1/2 slices,
would you have
a good Yelp review of there?
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Trump visited the border
in the town of Alamo, Texas.
He was like, "Thanks to me,
everyone will remember Alamo."
[ Light laughter ]
In the end, Trump didn't finish
building the wall,
and Mexico never paid for it,
but other than that,
pretty good.
Pretty good.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You guys having fun?
You guys having a good time?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great.
[ Applause ]
While Trump was at the border,
he engaged in one
of his favorite traditions
and signed
a section of the wall.
Watch this.
[ Light laughter ]
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Trump was like, "Okay, wall,
you're now officially pardoned."
[ Laughter ]
Right now,
writing on his border wall
is the only place
where Trump's allowed to post.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
So that's two crimes he's
committed in the past week --
incitement of a riot
and graffiti.
[ Laughter ]
Times are tough
for Trump right now.
After he defaced the wall,
he was sent to live with
his auntie and uncle in Bel Air.
[ Laughter ]
Before leaving
to go visit the wall,
Trump spoke to reporters
and was asked about the riot
at the Capitol.
And listen to this.
[ Engine rumbling ]
-So if you read my speech --
and many people have done it --
it's been analyzed,
and people thought that
what I said
was totally appropriate.
-I just got to quote Seinfeld
and say,
"Who are these people?!
Who are these people?!"
"They're the people of the..."
"Who are these people?!"
[ Laughter ]
By the way, that wasn't a jet
engine in the background --
that was 300 million Americans
sighing at the same time.
[ Laughter ]
And this is big -- last night,
Trump and Vice President Pence
met in person
inside the Oval Office,
marking the first time they had
spoken since last week's riot.
Things quickly got off to an
awkward start when Trump said,
"So, I think
someone owes me an apology."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we've all been
in Pence's shoes, though.
You know what I mean?
That uncomfortable meeting
with your boss
after he sent a crazed mob of
vengeful rioters to zip-tie you.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
But Trump tried to make nice.
He even gave Pence
a "Sorry I almost got you
killed" meat and cheese platter
from Harry & David.
[ Laughter ]
I never saw that in that bill --
pamphlet I got there.
Well, speaking
of the Vice President,
earlier tonight,
the House voted on a resolution
urging Pence to
invoke the 25th Amendment.
It's a tough choice for Pence --
invoke the 25th
and have MAGA Nation hate you,
or refuse and still
have MAGA Nation hate you.
You could tell
Pence was nervous
'cause he spent all day
slamming milks
like it was Friday at 5:00 p.m.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, Mike Pence is being called
on to invoke the 25th Amendment,
and Trump is not happy.
But I'm not sure
Trump understands
what the 25th Amendment
actually does.
To be honest, I'm not sure if he
knows what most amendments do.
For example --
-Oh, here we go.
-Tariq, what's up?
-Let me guess --
you're gonna make fun of Trump
for not knowing what
any of the amendments mean.
-I mean, yeah, that was --
that was the plan.
-And each joke, it'll pop up,
like, as a graphic,
so that everyone can see it
and laugh about it.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. Right.
I do -- I do comedy.
-I know exactly
how this will go down.
So, the top of the screen will
say the name of the amendment,
like the First Amendment,
and then under that, you'll say
what Trump thinks it means,
like he thinks
the First Amendment is...
[ Laughter ]
Or -- Or you'll show
the Fifth Amendment,
and Trump knows that one as...
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-And then -- then you do, like,
the Seventh Amendment
or something.
And Trump --
he thinks that one is...
-Ohh!
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-And then you'll finish it off
with the 25th Amendment,
which Trump thinks is...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is -- Is -- Is that
how it's going to go?
-Uh, yeah. You nailed it.
[ Chuckles ]
-Seems like a fun bit.
You should do it.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Great, we'll do it tomorrow.
-Looking forward to it.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, lots of people
are distancing themselves
from the President,
including New England Patriots
head coach Bill Belichick.
Last night, he said
he won't accept the Presidential
Medal of Freedom from Trump.
Yep. It was a hard decision
for the coach.
I heard he bought
a new hooded, sleeveless tuxedo
for the occasion.
[ Laughter ]
Here's some good news --
yesterday, Governor Cuomo vowed
that New York will legalize
recreational marijuana.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Great job.
New Yorkers have spent
almost a year with nothing to do
but sit at home
and watch Netflix.
Now you legalize weed?
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Who are these people?!"
I think New York is ready
for legal weed.
Just look at
the Statue of Liberty.
Our most famous symbol
is green, wearing a bathrobe,
and holding up a lighter.
[ Laughter ]
Some entertainment news --
during last night's episode
of "The Bachelor,"
the women played a game called
"Capture the Heart."
And one contestant, Victoria,
had an interesting way of
describing the other team.
Listen to this.
-Whoo!
[ Laughter ]
-Gestures?
"And, Matt, he's like
a K-night of the Round Table."
[ Laughter ]
Later in the episode,
there was some drama
between Victoria
and another contestant.
And Victoria tried to say that
they don't mix well,
like oil and water,
but, instead, she said this.
-Yeah, and I think
that we can --
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Actually,
that goes pretty well together.
"I mean, we're like
peanut butter and...jelly?"
[ Laughter ]
You could tell
her face was like,
"I don't think this is right,"
but her mouth was like,
"Nope, I'm going for it, yeah."
[ Laughter ]
We're laughing,
but tomorrow, she's getting the
Presidential Medal of Freedom.
That amazing?
[ Laughter and applause ]
Isn't that amazing?
[ Applause ]
And finally,
I saw that Ben & Jerry's
has started selling
its own frozen dog treats.
Trust me, once weed
becomes legal in New York,
that'll be just ice cream.
What a show we have
for you tonight --
she stars in the new movie
"Locked Down" on HBO Max.
Anne Hathaway is here tonight!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, she's the host of
"A Little Late with Lilly Singh"
on NBC --
Lilly Singh is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got great music
from Jazmine Sullivan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Be sure to tune in
tomorrow night --
Riz Ahmed and Angela Bassett
will be here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got an all--
we got an all-new
"Freestylin' with The Roots."
You guys excited to do that one?
-Uh. Yeah, yeah.
-Sure.
-Yup.
-Nasty.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, it's a fun bit.
Anyway...
You guys have a good day today?
-Pretty good. Yeah.
-It was fine.
-Yeah. Same.
-Nasty.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-I had a good day --
I had a good day, too.
Did you guys have anything good
for lunch or anything?
-Um, no, not really.
-The usual.
-I microwaved some salmon, so...
-Nasty.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, everyone should...
Everyone should check out
"Freestylin'" tomorrow.